cracker
traditionally snowballs are packed tight
for wintertime fun but they've been
known to start some serious trouble
and just this past week in the news
leaving one Wisconsin city in a flurry
these new sources stated that we had a
brand new ordinance enacted by our mayor
prohibiting having a snowball fight the
Wausau deputy police chief and the mayor
created a video to set the record
straight the ordinance that I just read
was enacted by our wasa Common Council
in 1962 long before I was even born we
do like to have a great time here in the
city of wasa the city ordinance bans
throwing projectiles and lumps snowballs
into the same category as rocks missiles
and other items that can cause serious
harm kids think they're throwing
snowballs and they're actually throwing
ice balls
the band's only effective on public
property and it's not something that's
often enforced this ordinance is in
place for the safety of our community
the Wausau police department has used
this ordinance and issued citations
about ten times in the last 15 years and
only two of those times were over the
issue of throwing snowballs a fun
snowball fight is a fun snowball fight
and that's not something we enforce this
ordinance with allowing everyone to
bundle up and let their inner child play
in the snow back of the noggin probably
after that hit the city councilman or
decriminalizing snowball fights at a
meeting next month I love it because
those were all police officers around
him that were throwing the snowballs
that was way to make fun of yourself
best best snowball scenes in movies
Christmas Story Dumb and Dumber or elf
Oh
elf coming dumber I think else yeah none
of them are bad America please vote Jeff
on Twitter yes
you